[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله بدا امير دوله
الكويت صباح الاحمد الجابر الصباح مباحثات
مع كبار المسؤولين الايرانيين في طهران
وذلك خلال زياره تستغرق يومين وتاتي في ظل
علاقه متذبذبه بين ايران ودول الخليج
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي ابرز القضايا والملفات التي
يبحثها امير الكويت خلال زيارته الحاليه
الى ايران والى اي حد يمكن ان تسهم هذه
الزياره في دفع وتعزيز العلاقات بين ايران
ودول
[موسيقى]
الخليج خمس مذكرات تفاهم في مجالات
الاقتصاد والسياحه وتبادل المعلومات
الامنيه ينتظر ان توقعها الكويت وايران
اثناء زياره امير الكويت الشيخ صباح
الاحمد الجابر الصباح الحاليه الى طهران
لكن الزياره التي تستغرق يومين وتجمع امير
الكويت بكبار المسؤولين الايرانيين تحمل
اجندتها قضايا وملفات تتجاوز هموم ومصالح
البلدين الى ما هو اشمل او هكذا يتصور لها
بالنظر لل الحفاوه التي احيطت بها الزياره
والظروف التي تعيشها المنطقه
حاليه الى على الرحب والسعه يستقبل امير
دوله الكويت في اول زياره له في منصبه
الحالي الى طهران يزورها وهو يتراس اهم
مؤسستين اقليميين عربيتين فهو الرئيس
الحالي لمجلس التعاون الخليجي والقمه
العربيه معا بهذا المعنى تكف زيارته عن ان
تكون بروتوكوليا ذات صله بعلاقات بين
دولتين لتشمل ملفاتها تعقيدات العلاقه بين
الدول على ضفتي الخليج تغير الكثير في
المنطقه قبل ان يبدا التقارب فعلى خلاف ما
كان متوقعا توصل الامريكيون والروس في
جنيف العام الماضي الى اتفاق يقضي بتجريد
سوريا من سلاحها الكيميائي تراجعت طبول
الحرب وتزايدت معها هواجس خليجيه بانصراف
الامريكيين عن المنطقه تجددت هذه الهواجس
ولاحقا تحولت الى مخاوف لدى البعض بتوصل
طهران ومجموعه 5 واح الى اتفاق حول برنامج
ايران النووي تغيران كان حاسمين وباعث
للقلق لدى دول في المنطقه ما دفع الاداره
الامريكيه الى ارسال وزير خارجيتها لطمانه
حكامها لكن الهواجس ظلت كما هي عليه
فطهران ما زالت تواصل دعم رئيس يقتل شعبه
كما يقول زعماء في المنطقه كما ان
تدخلاتها في لبنان والبحرين بل واليمن لم
تتوقف والخشيه كما قيل وتردد على السنه
مقربين من دوائر صنع القرار في المنطقه ان
يكون اتفاق جنيف النووي مقدمه لجائزه اكبر
قد تقدم للايرانيين فيما يخص الادوار
وهوامش التحرك في الاقليم باسره لابد من
ايضاحات اذا هذا ما فعله الرئيس الايراني
حسن روحاني في مسقط اضافه الى جوله قام
بها وزير خارجيته محمد جواد ظريف ولاختبار
ما بدا حسن نيه بادر وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الى دعوه ظريف لزياره بلاده لكن
الوزير الايراني قال اخيرا انه قد لا
يتمكن من القيام بها لاسباب اجرائيه تتعلق
بتضارب موعدها المقترح مع موعد مفاوضات
نوويه مرتقبه تتقدم بهذا ولو رمزيا
استحقاقات التوقيت الدولي على الاقليمي
لضى طهران بينما تظل زيارات المسؤولين
تتحرك وتدور في تلك البرهه التي تسبق
التفاوض نفسه وتمهد
له موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
طهران محمد شريعتي مستشار الرئيس الاسبق
محمد خاتمي ومن عمان الكاتب الصحفي عبد
الوهاب بدر خان ومن الكويت الدكتور عبد
الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت نرحب بضيوفنا الكرام استاذ
عبد الله الشايجي المسؤوليات الخارجيه
والاقليميه التي يطلع بها امير دوله
الكويت في هذه المرحله واثناء زيارته هذه
تجعل من
العسير ان نفصل بين يعني الاهداف الكويتيه
والاهداف الخليجيه والاهداف العربيه من
زيارته وضمن اجندته لهذا نسال هنا ما هي
اجنده امير الكويت في
طهران طبعا اشكرك ارحب فيك وارحب بالضيوف
وكذلك بالمشاهدين زياره سمو امير دوله
الكويت اليوم زياره يترقبها الجميع الجميع
ينظر لها بانها زياره مهمه هناك هنا ك
طبعا الامير يمثل ثلاثه يعني ابعاد معا هو
رئيس دوله الكويت وهو رئيس القمه العربيه
ورئيس القمه الدوره الحاليه يضا دول مسس
التعاون الخليجي فهو يتكلم بلسان الكويت
وبلسان العرب وبلسان الخليجيين معا وهذا
يكسب الزياره اهميه كبيره ولكن
يعني الملاحظ ان الانفراج التي يمكن ان
تحدث بالتقارب الامريكي الايراني منذ
الخريف الماضي وا ما تصريحات الامير سعود
الفيصل قبل فتره قصيره من استقبال وزير
الخارجيه الايراني وكذلك الحوار مع ايران
حول القضايا الشائكه في المنطقه كل هذه
الامور يبدو بان الايرانيين نحن نعول اكثر
على نجاح هذه الزياره من الايرانيين يعني
نحن في تساؤلات في الكويت لماذا لم يكن
وزير رئيس الدوله في ايران في استقبال
امير الكويت لماذا لم ينقل التلفزيون
الايراني الرسم التلفزيونات
الخاصه التوقيع على بروتوكلات وعلى
اتفاقيات التعاون لماذا صرح اليوم ايضا
وزير الخارجيه الايراني بانه لن يقوم
بزياره للسعوديه ضمن يعني اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه
دولون الاي على هامش طبعا دول المؤتمر
منظمات التعاون الاسلامي في الشهر القادم
في 18 الشهر الحالي فهذه كلها يعني تعطينا
بان هناك رغبه حقيقيه بزياره امير الكويت
لنقل صوره واضحه من قبل الدول دوله الكويت
والدول الخليجيه والدول العربيه بنوايا
حسنه تجاه ايران وان ايران يعني ان تنظر
الى هذه الزياره
كبادرة انا اخت اختم فيها يعني ايران
عليها ان تتصالح والدوله تتكلم بلسان واحد
بدون تهديدات من الحرس الثوري وكذلك على
ايران ان تقرن القول بالفعل حول ي قضايا
ربح الطرفين وليس عمليه يعني موازنه ما
نسميها يعني لعبه يخسر فيها ك كلا الطرفين
المعادله الصفريه نعم استاذ محمد شريعتي
يعني تساؤل مهم طرحه دكتور شيشي ايران اذا
كانت ستستقبل اميره الكويت وهذه اول زياره
له كامير الكويت منذ توليه الاماره في في
في الدوله المسؤوليه في الدوله لماذا لم
يكن حتى على الاقل من باب اظهار الاهتمام
بهذه الزياره لم يكن رئيس الكويت رئيس
عفوا
ايران في استقباله في المطار
مثلا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا ايضا
احييكم واحيي الضيوف ولكن اقول بان
نقول نحن في ايران بان دوله الكويت
علاقاتها جيده مع ايران ولكن اعلام الكويت
شويه فيها تامل بالنسبه لمواقف ايران اولا
استقبال الاعلام الايراني ايض وكل الامراء
حتى نعم بالنسبه لا الاعلام
الايراني المحافظين نعم ولكن الاصلاحيين
كلما يبدون رغبه في التعامل مع كل دول ل
الخليج لا
يقابل للاسف انقطع الاتصال بالسيد شريعتي
استاذ عبد الوهاب بدر خان وزير الخارجيه
الايراني كما اشار الى ذلك الدكتور عبد
الله شيجي اعتذر عن تلبيه دعوه وزير
الخارجيه
السعودي الى الرياض في اطار او في على
هامش مؤتمر منظمه التعاون الاسلامي التي
كان مقترحا ان تتم في وقت لاحق من هذا
الشهر الى اي حال ربما قد يكون هذا دليلا
على توجه
ايران نحو الخليج وعدم استقبال الرئيس
الايراني لامين الكويت هل يمكن ان نقراه
كاشاريل عدم استقبال رئيس روحاني لامير
الكويت في
المطار يجب ان نستمع الى شرح حول
البروتوكول بالنسبه ال الى ايران ل لنتاكد
من انه ليس هناك ا يعني عمل غير لائق
خصوصا ان امير الكويت تبع الزياره وبشكل
طبيعي بالنسبه الى الى زياره محمد جواد
ظريف الى السعوديه على هامش والاجتماع مع
مع المسؤولين السعوديين على هامش الاجتماع
اجتماع منظمه التعاون الاسلامي ا العذر
الذي قدمه ظريف بان هناك مفاوضات نوويه
عذر يعني يمكن ان يكون مقبولا ولكن يجب ان
نلاحظ بانه منذ
وجه الامير سعود الفيصل الدعوه في الال
عشر من الشهر
الماضي الى الى ايران لم يكن ال الرد على
مستوى الدعوات والنداءات التي سمعناها من
مسؤولين ايرانيين بعد فوز روحاني بانهم
مستعجلون لتحسين العلاقات مع دول الخليج
ولا سما السعوديه يبدو ان ايران كانت
لديها حسابات في
شهري سبتمبر واكتوبر
الماضيين بانها تريد البدء بتحسين
العلاقات مع دول الخليج لان هذا يدعم
موقفها في في المفاوضات النوويه ولكن
طالما ان ان السعوديه لم تستجب في ذلك
الوقت لانها لم تكن لديها اي اسباب او اي
موجبات حقيقه للاستجابه لمثل هذه النداءات
اما الان فاصبحت السعوديه جاهزه للتفاوض
كما قال سعود الفيصل انما نرى ان ايران هي
التي
ليست مستعده وليست جاهزه تريد الان ان
تركز على
المفوض استاذ عب ال يعني بدر خان ضيفنا
الان هو جاهز ايضا للرد لانه عاد التواصل
معه مره اخرى لك ان تكمل ما بدات سيد محمد
شريعتي بخصوص تساؤلات ضيفين الكريمين
استاذ عبد الوهاب برخان واستاذ الدكتور
عبد الله الشيشي
نعم بالنسبه لى البروتوكول كما راينا في
سلطان عمان ايضا كان الاستقبال في سع اباد
وليس في المطار هذا بروتوكول منجز في
ايران وليس وعلاقات مع دوله الكويت مع
امير الكويت علاقات جيده وثابته وانا اقول
واعلق على خلاف العلاقات المتذبذبه مع دول
الخليج احيانا ايران وخاصه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكن علاقاتها مع الكويت
لم تكن متذبذبه لان الكويت ايضا بنت
علاقاتها دون ان تنظر الى من يحكم من يكون
في الدوله وهي علاقات راسخه وسوف يلتقي
ايضا القائد بالنسبه لهذه المساله طبي
وايضا بالنسبه الى العلاقات خاصه بعد
الحرب الخليجيه الثانيه كانت علاقات
الكويت مع ايران علاقات ثابته وخاصه ان
سفيرها سفير ثابت لم يتغير كبقيه الدول
وهذا اثر في ثبات العلاقات بين البلدين
والكويت تحمل ايضا النوايا خليجيه ونوايا
عربيه الى ايران واظن
بانها العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران ايضا
تحتاج الى دفعه وليست الى وساطه ولا اظن
ان الكويت ولو انه مؤهل لانه لان علاقاته
في المنطقه خاصه مع دول المنطقه مع العراق
مع بقيه الدول يعني عاديه وهذا يؤثر
بالنسبه الى الحساسيات الموجوده في طهران
دكتور عبد الله شيجي يعني كانت هناك اشاره
الى زيا
رئيس ايران الى سلطنه عمان كانت هناك ايضا
زياره لوزير الخارجيه الايراني الى قطر
الى
الامارات الى الكويت هنا نتساءل في ضوء ما
يتم الحديث عنه من تذبذب في العلاقات بين
الخليج وايران هل تتحدث دول الخليج بلسان
واحد فيما يخص المخاوف التي ظلت تعبر عنها
تجاه سياسه ايران هل هناك حد ادنى من
الاتفاق حول تحديد هذه المخاوف بين دول
الخليج طبعا بالطبع يعني هناك موقف خليجي
واضح في القضايا التي تصدر عبر بيان مشترك
وبيان القمم الخليجيه وما يصدره ايضا في
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه الول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والذي يعبر عنه ايضا الامين العام
لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وكثير منها
واخرها يعني كان قبل مده انتقاد شديد
لايران لتدخلها بشؤون دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وخلطها الاوراق مثلا واذكر هنا ب
تصريح مهم في البيان ختامي لوزراء
الخارجيه دول التعاون الخليجي للامين
العام وصف تدخلات ايران بدول الخليج
بالمستفزة
حاول ان يعني في الحرب البارده بين امريكا
وروسيا كان هناك فتره ما يسمى هدنه او
تعايش سلمي دي طانت فنحن الان نريد ان نصل
الى ديتان الى تعايش سلمي مع ايران الى
الى معادله ربح
مشتركه ايران تعاني من عقوبات شرسه ضدها
تشلها كليا ايران لا لا يتم استقبال
مسؤوليها في الدول الفاعله في النظام
العالمي ولا يزورونها وكذلك لا توجد صفقات
تجاريه مهمه ايران مكبله بالعقوبات وايران
تدرك بان عليها ان تغير من نمطها حسن
روحاني هي فرصه مواتيه جدا ونامل ان لا
تتكرر تجربه خاتمي نحن نريد ان نرى ايران
البراجماتيه التي تعتقد بانها يمكن ان
تتعايش تبتعد عن فكر الثوره الذي كانت
تريد ان تصدره والذي الان موجوده فيه في
بعض الدول بما فيها سوريا لهذا السبب هناك
تقاطع خطير في المشروعين الان واضحين
مشروع عربي تقوده السعوديه الى حد كبير في
قضايا في اشتباك مباشر مع مع ايران في في
سوريا في العراق في لبنان في اليمن في دول
الخليج وهذه الحرب البارده مستمره وللاسف
يعني انا اتاسف عندما سمعت بان كنت انا من
المتامن وال يعني الدافعين بان نرى وزير
الخارجيه الايراني لاول مره يصل الى
السعوديه ويبدا كسر الجليد بين الطرفين
بما ينعكس ايجابا على الوضع في العراق
وسوريا ولبنان ولكن للاسف
ال اير اعتقد ان اان دور قد انها الفرصه
مواتيه لتكسر الجليد الان كما ق تعال هو
قالان معد الزياره تزامن مع مع مع مفاوضات
حول الملف النووي الايراني على كل حال نحن
سنحاول ان نبحث بعد قليل بعد الفاصل افاق
نجاح الذي يمكن ان تحرزه زياره امير
الكويت الى طهران في تعزيز العلاقات
الايرانيه الخليجيه نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
مشاهدنا
الكرام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش العلاقات الخارجيه الايرانيه في ضوء
الزياره امير الكويت الى طهران نرحب
بضيوفنا الكرام مره اخرى سيد محمد شريعي
ايران تقول بانها تراهن على زاره امير
دوله الكويت لكي يعني تساهم هذه الزياره
في تعزيز الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
ولكن يبدو ان ايران لم تغير من سياساتها
كما يرى الخليجيون ايران ما زالت تتدخل في
شؤون دول المنطقه
الداخليه ايران ما زالت يعني لديها لديها
نفوت في لبنان في اليمن في سوريا ما الذي
ستقدمه ايران لدول الخليج كي تطوي هذه
الصفحه اذا كانت نواياها صادقه فعلا في
احداث انفراج على صعيد
العلاقات في
اعتقادي حكومه روحاني كانت ستقدم الكثير
لل دول ل الجوار
وخاصه دول المنطقه
وهذا التعامل
مع زياره السيد ظريف الذي ابدا مرات بانه
جاهز ان يذهب الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولم يكن هناك جواب
وذهب الى الامارات ذهب الى عمان ذهب الى
الكويت واظن
بانه قطار العلاقات مع السعوديه انطلق
وهذه الاشكاليات الجزئيه هذه سوف ترفع لان
المهم الايرادات بالنسبه ل حدث المشاكل
ولكن مثلا بالنسبه لسوريا صحيح ان موقف
ايران يختلف كثيرا ولكن الكويت ايضا راينا
ليست متحمسه بالنسبه لموقف مثلا قطر او
موقف المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالنسبه
لسوريا ولكن لا شك انها تضغط في هذا
الجانب بانها تحاد ايران على الاقل
بالنسبه لسوريا وكان من الممكن ان تتغير
سياسه ايران بالنسبه لسوريا
لولا لو كانت المعارضه تدرس القضايا ولا
تنتهج مثلا لقاء مع السيده مريم رجوي
واخرين هناك
ايضا اغلاط و حت حتى ل نخلط الاوراق سيد
شريعتي سيد شريعتي يعني هل تعتقد بان هل
تراهن طهران على ان السعوديه ستقبل باي
تقارب بينها وبين ايران على حساب اسمار
سيطره سوريا على على الكثير من البلدان
العربيه ويعني بص
نفوذها سيطره ايران عفوا على الدان
العربيه لا انا اقول على ان سياسه لا لا
انا اقول ان سياسه روحاني في سوريا
بالنسبه لسوريا كانت تتغير وغير سياسه
احمدي نجاد ولكن الظروف
تهيات لان لا تتغير هذه السياسه عمليا وان
كان انه نامل بعد نحن في هذا التغير الى
مرحله انه يكون يفكرون في الشعب السوري
اكثر مما يفكرون في النظام السوري ولكن
باليات مختلفه استاذ عب بدرخان ما هي
اوراق الضغط التي تراهن عليها دول الخليج
لربما في حمل ايران على تغيير سياساتها
التي تعتبرها مثيره للقلق
يعني ملاحظه عابره انا لا اعتقد ان الرئيس
روحاني هو صانع السياسه في سوريا انما
الحرس الثوري
والمرشد علي
خ هذا هو هذا هذا هذا امر معروف بالنسبه
الى اوراق الضغط حاليا دول الخليج لا لا
تملك الكثير من اوراق الضغط سوى ان ايران
لكي تحصل او تثبت النفوذ الذي حصلت عليه
في في المنطقه سواء في المشرق العربي او
في الخليج يلزم يلزمها ايران يلزمها ان
تكون متوافقه مع دول الخليج وان تقبل دول
الخليج بهذا النفوذ ولكن حاليا في اي
مفاوضات لابد من ان يطرح موضوعان بالغ
بالغي يعني الصعوبه الاول هو لماذا او كيف
توصلت ايران الى قياده او او اداره تنظيم
القا ده وتنظيمات اخرى مثل داعش ولماذا
فعلت ذلك وباي هدف امتدادا من من سوريا
الى العراق الى الى الى جنوب اليمن والامر
الاخر هو لماذا تريد ايران ان تواصل عسكره
الطائفه الشيعيه
والشحن الطائفي في كل المجتمعات التي توجد
في يوجد فيها طائفه شيعيه ومن دون ان تكون
مضطهده كما في في الكويت مثلا هذا هذه هذا
من من الموضوعات الشائكه التي يجب ان تكون
ايران واضحه فيها و هذا ما يجب حله فعلا
بشكل عاجل نعم يعني هنا انا مضطر لاتجاوز
الدكتور الشيشي ليرد الاستاذ محمد شريعتي
لانه يبدو ان لديه رد على ما يقول استاذ
عبد بدر خان في نصف دقيقه استاذ شريعتي
نعم
نعم نعم انا اقول على ان صحيح ان ليس ما
تطلبه السعوديه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بيد السيد روحاني كل ما تطلبه ولكن الطريق
والمفتاح والباب هو العلاقات مع الحكومه
كما كانت السيد خاتمي السيد خاتمي لم تكن
هذه كل هذه المساله ولكن
راينا دكتور شيجي دكتور شيجي عذرا عذرا
شريعه القطعه دكتور شيجي انا اعتذر ان
تاخرنا كثيرا لكي نعطيك الكلمه ولكن اعود
مره اخرى الى مساله الرهان رهان الخليجيين
على ماذا يعولون في اقناع ايران بتعديل
سياساتها التي تشكل مخاوف لدى
الخليجيين يعني المشكله تبقى فيرا مثل ما
ذكرت في البدايه هناك مشروع ايراني واضح
يصطدم مع المصالح الدول العربيه بمعظمها
ودول الخليج ايران لا تزال غارقه بين
الثوره والدوله لم تصل الى الدوله من يصنع
القرار ليس حسن روحاني كما يريد ان يهمنا
صديقنا محمد شريعتي في في ايران قبل ذلك
محمد خاتمي بكى في نهايه ولايه الثانيه
بانه ليس لديه صلاحيات حسن روحاني منذ ان
اتى زاد التوغل الايراني في كل الدول
العربيه لم يتغير شيء الرهان هو ان ايران
البراجماتيه اذا كان في براغماتيه في
ايران هي ان تعلم بان نزفها سيستمر اذا لم
تقم ب ما هو مطلوب منها لان تتعايش مع دول
الخليج ان تتوقف عن التدخل بشؤون الدول
الخليجيه وكما اتفق مع زميلي الدكتور عبد
الوهاب بدر خان ايضا عسكر المجتمعات
الشيعيه والتدخل في الشؤون وال نكر
نورهه وليس دور تصعيد حتى لا نكرر الكلام
يعني يعني بالنسبه للخليجيين كيف ينظرون
الى هذا التفاهم الغربي الايراني حول
الملف النووي واي تفاهم الى اي حد قد يغير
من سياسات ايران اتجاه الخليج هل الى
التقارب ام الى مزيد من
التصلب يعني هو طبعا في ترحيب خليجي
بالتقارب الامريكي الايراني اذا ادى الى
وقف برنامج ايران النووي ولكن ليس على
حساب ما يسمى الصفقه الكبرى التي تكون على
حساب دول الخليج مقابل اعطاء ايران يد
طوله في قضايا وملفات المنطقه ولهذا السبب
الامريكيون سعوا بشكل واضح من الرئيس
اوباما الى وزير الخارجيه ال وزير الدفاع
لطمن دول الخليج بالتعاون المشترك وبيضا
انظمه دفاعيه واسلحه جماعيه لهذه الدول
ولكن لا يزال الموضوع بحاجه الى المزيد من
البحث لان هناك صراع كبير موجود الان بين
مشروعين كبيرين في المنطقه
وعلينا ان نكون نحن يعني نطمئن الى ايران
التي نريد ان نكسبها ك شقيق وزميل وصديق
وايضا ان ان لا تتدخل في شؤون الدول لان
هذا التدخل سينعكس سلبا على الامن
والاستقرار ويعسكر
المجتمعات وايضا يزيد من الانفاق على
التسلح بدل الانفاق على التنميه والشراكه
مع ايران اذا ما كانت بالفعل العقلانيه
كما كما يعني نامل ب زيارات الامير ان
يرسل هذه الرسائل دكتور عبد الله الشجي
رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
شكرا لك ونشكر الاستاذ عبد الوهاب بدر خان
الكاتب الصحفي من عمان والشكر موصول لمحمد
شريعتي مستشار الرئيس الاسبق محمد خاتمي
كان معنا من طهران بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج معرا خبر نتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في م وراء خبر جديد شكرا لكم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته